I love that video because that's what
the sins is all about empowering you to
play with life your Sims can do all the
things you like to do or all the things
you wish you could do or maybe try out
those things you shouldn't do it's all
up to you you rule and we're gonna keep
giving you more life to play with since
we launched last year the sims 4 has
been getting bigger and better every
month here's just a taste in November it
was time for your sims to splash around
and have a pool party we invited your
sims to an outdoor retreat in January
with campfires and bear costumes April
was all about getting to work you go
girl
the world of new crust arrived in May
for you to fill with your creations
last month we treated your sims to a spa
day and some love in the hot tub that's
just a few of the new things we've
introduced in the past year and we're
gonna keep on growing the sims 4 and
giving you more ways to play with life
every month now here's something big for
later this year I'm excited to announce
the sims 4 get-together expansion pack
coming this November now we all know
that our lives are better and way more
fun with our friends this is my sim and
she's with her friends and now her life
and the lives of your sims can be more
fun too as they hang out with their
friends in Windham burg a new world
that's a wonderful blend of European
modern culture and historical style it's
a world full of cool hot spots and fun
new experiences for your sins and their
friends to discover together see my sim
is having a great time dancing so let's
check out some sins now as they live it
up and get together
wherever it's going I'm gonna chase a
little small
this won't be forever so I try to fight
so that's get together our new expansion
pack for The Sims 4